The human brain is complex and people's brains are different based on a whole bunch of different things.
But as America enters yet another election season
I gotta know, does our physiology shape our politics or vice versa?
This ought to get that comment section jumping jumping like it's 1999. Theme song time!
I'm gonna put this brain down and do the words.
Do our brains modulate our behavior or does our environment modulate our behavior, which then modulates our brain activation?
Well, this is classic nature/nurture debate. But research suggests it could be both.
Before we get politically picante, let's talk about research.
People have built whole frameworks based on similarities and differences in behavioral expression and their correlates in the brain.
Research usually falls within the lanes of the whole brain size, specific brain structure size,
and activation of different brain regions.
Even genetics have been called into question to explain why we believe what we believe and politics are the perfect example.
Alright, hold up.
We can't go anywhere without some important definitions. The word liberalism as I'll be using it is the belief that government should be
active in supporting social and political change and
conservatism a political philosophy based on tradition and social stability
stressing established institutions and preferring gradual development to abrupt change. Now I got check with my producers, how's the comments section looking so far?
Well, it will. Throw a meter up there so we can see how hot it gets. Throw a bing on there. Bing! All right.
Let's start with growing up. We all grow up right that's not controversial, right? Okay, comment section is looking cool.
But we all have ideas programed into us by the media we're exposed to,
by our friends and family and by our general environment.
But research suggests that it may be in our genetics. How? We got CNN Town Hall debates raised in our DNA?
Like adenine and guanine like...
No.
A 2014 study surveying 12,000 twins identical
and fraternal from all over the world proposes that up to 60% of our political beliefs come from our environment,
leaving up to 40% who come from our genetics, Peter Hatemi, the lead researcher on the study
suggests that we inherit some of how we process information from our parents and that manifests in society today as political attitudes.
Further evidence from a 2015 study suggests that genes with receptors for the neurotransmitter dopamine
are associated how liberal or conservative we are. That study found that among women who were liberal,
62% were carriers for a certain was receptor genotype that had been previously associated with traits like extraversion and
seeking new impulsive adventures. Meanwhile among highly conservative women those receptive genotypes fell to around 37.5%.
How we doing? How's that meter looking?
Low. Alright, let's heat this bad boy up. Throw a picture Colin Firth. Yeah that one. Yep. Same one. That dude. Yep.
Yeah that dude. You can be devilishly handsome and do science at the same time. I mean look at him not me.
He coauthored a paper in 2011, which get a man who can do both,
but it suggests that there are anatomical differences in the brains of younger adults on the liberal conservative axis.
His team discovered that liberalism is associated with higher gray matter volume of the anterior cingulate cortex aka the ACC.
And conservatism is associated with increased right amygdala size.
The activity of the anterior cingulate cortex has been related to decision making,
socially-driven interactions, and empathy. And the amygdala plays a key role in processing emotions and forms part of the limbic system,
Their research suggests that the liberal brains may be more conflict resolution driven while conservative brains are more
emotion driven. Further research finds that people with bigger amygdalas are also less likely to participate in protest movements.
Of course, all this research is correlational and not causal.
However, it does lead to interesting conversations about nature and nurture when it comes to biology and politics.
Okay, I can hear it. I can see it. Don't blame me. Blame Colin Firth. Still love you Colin.
Can't wait for Kingsman Three and Bridget Jones's Tumblr Account.
So let's talk about the elephant or donkey in the room: age. As our beliefs and behaviors shift so do our brains and it's likely
that our brains to change as our political views, a set of beliefs and behaviors change.
British research from 1964 to 2010 suggests that generational differences do affect vote choice between liberal or conservative candidates,
but it also proposes that people tend to vote more conservative as they get older.
So either die a liberal or live long enough to become a conservative? More research is needed,
but all this research taken together suggests that there are biological and environmental factors that can influence, may influence,
or be influenced by our politics.
Okay, so I can see that meter is just straight-up broken.
But I just reported facts y'all.
Lots of differences in genetics and neurological structures are reported for a bunch of different things.
Gender, race, athleticism, etc, etc.
The brain isn't necessarily partisan, but when we move to political extremes, it will affect our physiology and psychology, changing implicit attitudes we have,
memories and even our perceptual judgments. As we enter a super-polarized political arena, while our ideals and morals should definitely be upheld
it's important to bridge the partisan divide by investing in facts and a shared reality rather than creating our own.
Now it's a lot of information about your brain to put in your brain
so right now you probably need a little break just you know, grab some tea, crash in front of the TV and watch nothing in particular.
But did you know they've even apolitical entertainment television can influence your political opinion?
Check out that bad boy right here. And please be sure to subscribe to Seeker and thank you so so much for watching.